I'm very glad to introduce Jacob
Jacob Barker
um Jacob has a background in engineering
and computer science and disease
modeling his topic is the reference
model for disease propagation and Mist
to find data Fitness so we'll find out
what that's about
he's educated at the technion Israel
Institute of Technology and is acquired
experience in manufacturing and
Healthcare modeling from University of
Michigan
he is currently a freelancer
and he pursues his development effort in
this missed system
he has a few Flyers out here if anyone
is interested I'll pass them around just
pick one if if you need them
and I'll hand it over thanks
okay thank you for the introduction
I'm going to talk about two things one
of them is the reference model the other
one is Mist Mist stands for micro
simulation tool and
and the iPhone small is a model for
disease progression
um
probably not many people here know many
things about disease models so what are
those
disease models try to describe phenomena
that you find in clinical trials in the
sense those are those are typically
equations risk equations that give you
the probability of having a heart attack
or having a stroke or whatever phenomena
you are looking at
when you have such an equation you can
try to predict the future what might
happen to a certain population or a
certain person
this is the idea behind it but those are
equations that describe this phenomena
many times they are used to find out how
much it will cost the system uh or what
will be the quality of life of a
population if they have a certain
condition medical condition
however the
the
derived from a certain population
usually there's a big state of the data
upon which some analysis is made and
those equations are there those describe
the phenomena seen in that clinical
trial or in that data set they may not
always fit other populations
today there is an effort to uh
generalize this and extend this to work
another populations and the reference
model is one of these attempts there are
other types of attempts all around for
the world so
this is the current version of the
reference model uh it's still very
simple uh currently it's aimed at
diabetic populations uh however it can
be extended
um
you can see here free disease processes
heart attack is the first one second one
is stroke the third one is competing
mortality because people can get die out
of getting getting hit by a bus and not
necessarily by uh dying out of disease
um
the reference model is called to
reference model because it's based on
references to the literature the
information there is generally public uh
not proprietary not restricted there is
no access to individual data it's all
samoy data that exists somewhere but
actually there's much more summary data
than uh individual data think about it
if you have a data set a certain
population and that you have access to
you're not allowed to combine it to the
other data set you're not allowed to
give it to some other people however
when you publish information from a
clinical trial you put it publicly
everyone can access it and there are
many many of those so you can derive
information from this this way
um the reference model also is and this
is maybe the most important thing here
is a league of models it's not one model
it takes many many os equations and just
makes them compete against each other
trying to fit whatever was seen in past
clinical trials and it shows and gives
you the ability to run against multiple
multiple populations
so how does it work basically so
in the reference model you take a
population
uh this population you find it as samoy
data the system expands it to mock
individuals many many individuals to uh
that are extracted from this
data that is known
and this population is run through the
model
now each model each transition in the
model it can be a different risk
equation taken from a different Source
here I'm showing four Mis and four four
strokes can be possible
uh but let's say first time the system
runs with popular a certain population
it turns them and sees how many people
have an MI how many people have a stroke
after a certain amount of views and
compels those results to the actual
results observed in the same clinical
trial that population One belongs to
and then you can write down the
difference here for example the
difference was full and you can uh you
can change this metric if you really
want to you have some control over it
then the
does the same for equation number two
equation number three for an MI equation
number four for an MI and so on and so
forth it will root for stroke as well
and you can add hypotheses on top of it
because some things you don't
necessarily know and some of the
equations
may need some correction you can add
those corrections as hypotheses
basically you can conduct kind of a
virtual trial on top of the information
that's out there already
then after it's done for one population
we replace it for a different clinical
trial again we have all the data
available in the publication we run it
through the system
and we get a different set of results
and color coding the results
shows you very quickly what models are
better when where this information fit
well does it not fit not always those of
it between pieces of information
so this color Matrix are called the
fitness Matrix uh
basically it's a big yellow Matrix
I'm gonna leave now the reference model
for a minute and I'm going to talk about
Mists the micro simulation tool micro
simulation tool is free software that
was developed uh to run simulations
Monte Carlo simulations such as this it
has its own language its own graphical
user interface
it's built on python uh with all sorts
of nice libraries there
um but in a natural it's a Monte Carlo
simulation compiler
um
it's also and this is fairly recent only
in last few months it's now also a
population generator not only it can run
those multicolor simulations it can
generate populations
uh after to match statistics that you
find in the literature
and also missed
Mist runs over the cloud I want you to
remember this catchy phrase maybe you'll
be able to look it up later on
so it uses quite some computing power
this is an eight core machine that I had
that's after about two years of use got
fried
this is a real picture from a few weeks
ago but miss can also run over the cloud
the Amazon
ec2 Cloud
um
to run over the cloud if someone is
interested the technical people in how
it is done it uses a software called
style cluster
star cluster creates
a virtual cluster or on the Amazon cloud
cloud it does this from the command line
very very easily
um
and uh start this this cluster will run
some good engine so basically
if you have any software that runs on
some good engine you can use style
cluster to run it over the cloud you can
Define your own computers that you want
to use it for and
um
you can also uh use which kind of a
image you want to use I use an anaconda
Ami to on it so
um Anaconda not only offers a
distribution you can also find in Amazon
machine image that you can run and I use
it to run a Mist over the cloud and to
remember to help you remain remember the
sketchy phrase then missed doesn't run
over the cloud but really it does
there are some if you download Miss from
GitHub you'll be able to find some
sample code that shows you how to do
this
for a few minutes before I'm gonna go
back to the reference model
uh Mist now has the ability to generate
populations from the statistics that are
that are seen that are seen publications
of clinical trials so um today there was
a talk before by Alex is sitting here uh
they have access to individual data in
the clinical Medical Records I don't
have access to individual data and I
actually don't want it because once you
have this access you're kind of
constrained it's like a stone that you
have to carry around you're concerned by
all sorts of laws uh
there are many many uh there are many
many instances of public data that are
out there each clinical trial
publication and typically in the
clinical child publication you'll find
table one table one will describe your
statistics
the statistics of your population
an example I I
extracted from a publication
a large diabetics diabetes study that's
held in the UK it's called ukippds they
have many Publications this isn't from
number 33.
um you can see the table here has the
not the age the approximate age of the
of the cohorts mean and standard
deviation how many men how many women uh
how many of them were smoking blood
pressure cholesterol there are many more
characteristics I just put up a few just
so you can understand how a table one
looks like
now if I have the stable one I want to
generate
individuals that match this Statistics
apparently it's not that easy for this
I'll need to use a library called
inspired and I'm going to talk about
inspired quite a bit here so basically
inspired Mist allows me to generate the
populations I need
I only need publicly available summary
data and I don't have to access and
restock the data for to do this I'm much
more mobile and if you go to clinical
draw a true
clinicaltrials.gov today you'll find
many many publications of clinical
trials so there's plenty of data out
there that's available
on
things if you
physician girl at least this is his
picture from his website
um
we never met he wrote inspired and I
asked him about how to use the software
how to use his library in the day
basically he supplied me with the
sufficient instructions and actually
code that does that solves most of the
problem of population generation to a to
a Target
what is it what does aspired do it's a
bio-inspired computational python
Library
um I used genetic algorithms that are
provided there but it can do some other
things as well so I invite you to go and
check out his Library I'm going to
explain how Mist uses his library and
how it interacts with it
so when I generate the population within
Mist
um there are two things that I provide
to generate population first thing is
Generation expressions
those are expressions within best domain
specific language that tell you how each
individual will look like what the age
will be what uh blood pressure what
characteristics at all I want this
individual to have and how they interact
with each other they can be correlated
they can be uncorrelated independent and
I can also add inclusion and exclusion
criteria mainly assertion statements
within this so this is how one
individual looks like
however even in clinical trials this
does not always represent well the
entire population
so for this for the others to represent
well what happens in the uh in in the
actual real world you have to add
objectives objectives Define how the
entire population statistics looks like
it can Define what you reached at the
end
um basically it defines stable one that
you find in the clinical trial
um
it also since we're talking Monte Carlo
simulation it also removes the random
generation of issue of that usually
Monte Carlo has so how does it work so
Mist itself has its expression compiler
it compiles uh a python script the trans
Monte Carlo simulation that creates this
population this population matches those
generation Expressions it may not match
our statistics uh specifically one
example is when exclusion and exclusion
criteria skew the population
distribution this happens a lot in
clinical trials
um then objectives are added
an inspired kicks in and selects a
subset of that population that was
generated that matches the objectives so
we know how we generated those each one
of those individuals and
we also know that the subset was that
was selected is as close as possible to
what we wanted in the objectives
to define the objectives
um how does inspire do this so Mist
gives it instructions but basically this
goes on it's a genetic algorithm if we
have the set of candidates generated by
mist
inspired generates sub-populations out
of this initially it has a way to
generate multiple functions and
um
uh so uh you the user defines the user
mess defines what how to generate a mess
defines for uh Inspire how to generate
those functions
um
those sub-population full functions so
I'm showing here this that this this is
typically random showing some shapes
here that will be recognizable because
it will show the Next Generation what
happens
the system now evaluates each one of
those subpopulations it gives it the
score the score is how close are those
sub-population to the objectives to
table one that we want to have at the
end
um the best meaning minimal error are
selected to be the next generation
parents for the next generation and
those parents are now used to create
more examples from that population using
close-up over parameter operators and
mutation operators
now we have a new generation this
generation goes back to evaluation and
then selection variation and so on and
so forth
after many many generations the system
stabilizes and Mist has gives it
some criteria on how to terminate the
the generation and the best the best
score best scoring subpopulation you is
used this is the one that fits our
objectives the best the best Note again
it's not always possible to meet the
objectives we wanted from the population
you generated but this is the most
optimal thing that we can get within uh
within reason
it's better probably than what happens
in the real world
um
so I'm going to give an example of it of
why it's needed and how it is corrected
so why it says it's the first example we
want to generate 10 people this is
without using its Pilot We want to
generate 10 people with a certain
inclusion criteria that there will be
only ages 45 and up
um
the base population distribution meaning
the population were sampling form is
different for men and women uh different
ages different standard deviation and we
we're sampling it from population that's
equal men and women
this is how Mr yourself looks like you
actually write those expressions in
and the assertion here actually removes
those ages 45 and less
um
this is what this the system will
generate for us this is a simple example
however if we look at
what we got at the end
it does not fit what will started it
from the reason is the population got
skewed because of our exclu inclusion or
exclusion criteria and again this
happens in clinical trials a lot
whenever they publish table one
you will see things like that
sometimes they actually say that this
population is skewed in this parameter
or this parameter is skewed this way
sometimes they even use a different
statistic to describe it
um
however how does inspire corrected
inspired allows you to define the
objectives
here let's say we're using the same
population as before but now we're using
totally different objectives uh our mean
is now 50 and 5 and we want to have more
men and women for that tourism or
another let's say that this is how we it
went
in the clinical trial and we can also
add weights saying what kind of uh
objective is more important than others
now generating we're generating a
thousand people and selecting only 10
out of those
and the system will find the best stand
that will match our table one now we
have the mean the standard deviation and
we can see that number is much better
much much better now this is within the
constraints we could have generated more
people we could have added different
weights
but what I'm trying to show you is now
that we can remove this
um
this issue of inclusion exclusion
criteria affecting whatever happens in
table one at the end
I haven't tried it but now I believe
such technology can help uh uh in
designing table one before you actually
start recruiting Because you can now add
all your assumptions together and try to
model what might happen
um basically that's the idea
um
I'm going to jump ahead and remind you
what I started talking about the
reference model for this progression
the generation of population is was such
that we will have information to run
models upon
this is how a fitness Matrix the output
of the reference model looks like
to remind you the columns you see here
each one of them represents a different
model actually each one of those
quadrants The Columns are a different
model
um
and those are different populations
the colors are based on the Fitness in
each one of the cells that do this and
you cannot see it but if you I'll zoom
in even more you'll see there's a number
there this is the fitness score this
means how well the model that we have
fits the population results from that
clinical trial
um
The Columns you can see by the colors
that sometimes inflammation fits better
sometimes it it fits not not so well uh
but it's all relative the colors are
relative
um
I also add some added some assumptions
to the models
so I won't go into details if you're
interested later I'll talk about the
biomarker assumption but uh those are
the left and right models
separated by this line in the middle
um
I do want to talk however about the
date collection
basically it's temporal collection for
modeling for models getting outdated if
a model is based on a population that
was collected the data of collected for
was in the 70s or the 80s it may not
apply today
the 30 years of uh of medical progress
in treatment in prevention even people
don't behave the same so the models may
not apply the same way that they did in
the past but once you add some
coefficient to correct for those and
those are fairly simple apparently
models start behaving better
how can you see this you can see this
visually by the fact that
you have warmer colors on the top half
which doesn't have that correction but
you will see more green the glass is
going on the bottom half of the
of the of the diagram here so this shows
you the date correction and I can show
it the numbers is quite effective to get
better results
out of the same models so just tweaking
a Model A little bit makes it fit the
data better
how you can now put other hypotheses and
test them you can also do this at the
population level
the lines I added uh separate the
populations to how those were generated
from the statistics you don't know
whether those the populations how each
and the individuals uh
how the parameters for each individuals
are correlated their correlations is
something that is typically unpublished
and it's an issue so in this case I'm
taking two extreme approaches and saying
this half the top half in each one of
those
quadrons is
um
is is totally uncorrelated the
parameters of an individual are
independent age is not related to blood
pressure on the bottom half they are
fully correlated this means if the
person is old they also have blood
pressure they are in extreme risk to be
to have a bad cholesterol levels and so
on and so forth
so you can also see how basically the
range of behavior on the models on those
two assumptions and you can add more and
more assumptions and static data that is
out there already and this is what the
reference model is for basically
crunching uh the data that's out there
already already publicly available
you can also find out what the best
quality the row over here you can see it
mostly green
and you can also find phenomena that we
cannot understand
the stripes the red stripes over here
you see four of them because there are
several assumptions on models and
populations but this is base essentially
the same population we cannot explain
with existing models what happens there
we at this point in time really don't
know
um
so at this point I'll start wrapping up
and saying that this technology is only
generally it's its infancy some of the
ideas are still have to be accepted
but
uh
it's already going for example next
month there'll be uh the mounted
challenge will be taking it will be it
will be here in Stanford uh 18 and 19th
with the dates are correct
um so the reference model would be one
of the participants with several other
models there basically there is where
diabetes models compare and contrast
their models but the same technology
there's no reason why it shouldn't be
applied to other chronic diseases it
will it's not compatible with with
infectious diseases not spread diseases
but chronic diseases this technology
should fit
but the population generation uh aspects
that mist provides it's new and it's
totally unexplored uh so
audio is the hypothesis of maybe this is
worthwhile to maybe uh
model a clinical trial population
equipment before actually starting uh
recruiting for the clinical trial just
to see whether you are quoting from
populations then you can actually match
your table one that would be uh to plan
your table one ahead haven't tried it uh
it could be interesting to see whether
it's helpful or not uh
but think about it this modern's
recruitment
what about modeling other types of
recruitment efforts from population
maybe it's helpful there
uh
also the its population modeling we are
now at Facebook headquarters they deal
with populations
maybe there are some other applications
there that no one has thought of before
handling multiple populations
um
I will stop now I do want to acknowledge
uh many people that helped throughout
development the Anna Eismann about AC
years ago she came up with the idea of
collecting all this information uh
that's available in making sense out of
it uh statistician
uh and she had her own method Morton
Brown and Bill Hermann they helped held
this project enough time to help it
mature to the point that it's now today
Aaron Garrett helped a lot with inspired
uh I already mentioned this uh the guys
from Continuum analytics Ben zeitlin
created Ami
Ilan Chanel
develops Anaconda which is now the base
platform for developing mist and you
know reference model uh and there are
many many other uh
uh other people that deserve
acknowledgment maybe those mainly those
who develop a software and uh actually
answer all those posts on all the
message boards out there
Legacy Legacy funding from the NIH
started this project however today it's
independently developed and funded
without financial support
at this point I will stop and open up
for questions I hope I left enough times
for you to answer to ask questions and
there will be interest
foreign
let's say
um so in the first example we have the
you know they were giving
um a percentage smokers percentage mail
uh age ranges and and so on right
um but those are just the marginal um um
statistics for uh for that
um so
um
is it you so so how do you if the if the
researcher didn't report the the co-um
co-linearity of of uh smoking with sex
or with uh or you know uh how
you just kind of do your best and find
find whatever uh gives the best most
similar margins so this is exactly what
I've showed at the end uh you don't know
those things so two things about knowing
those things if they are not published
no one knows them
how can you drive any useful information
without without knowing and no one
publishes those so that's the first
thing
so when you see table one you think oh
this is my population this was clinical
trial was conducted and you don't see
all those inclusions they are written in
the report they do stay we had those in
solution inclusion criterias and
sometimes they even say that they skewed
the population but you're looking at
table one may derive even as a person
looking at it may not see the entire
scope of your population you don't see
the correlations you're talking about
you don't see a lot of things so this is
the problem
I agree with you the people who have
access to this data do not release it
publicly but if they don't elicit how
can anyone be learning from it
so under this some under those
conditions I'm doing the best possible
I'm saying you know what let's do the
best we can from what we have and
there's a lot of them out there a lot of
publication out there so uh I'm gonna go
back to the slide
this slide this line actually
divides two hypotheses on the population
generation so it actually shows you
these are the people that are highly
fully correlated this means if the
person here there's only one random
number that I generate to generate the
entire person and this number will tell
me if it's high this will be an old
person which is probably smoking a high
blood pressure high cholesterol levels
all the risks possible is probably this
possible already dying if I generated
High number already so this is fully
correlated this is totally Independence
the second half here and now if you want
the model now you can see whether the
results match over the fully correlated
and the totally independent group so
this gives you two extremes if those
match
then it gives you some information but
if those don't then you know
oh we have a problem here maybe
something either on the data is
different maybe we cannot explain it so
far you didn't have this map this is a
map so I'm trying to create this map
from available data I'm unrestricted by
all sorts of laws like you are you have
instructions and you cannot move your
data it's like it's loads it's like a
stone that you cannot carry around
uh yes and no because you cannot
de-identify it and you do do this but
even the identified data you can there
are instructions on this we know that
but this is summary data this is totally
unrestricted this is a bunch of numbers
somewhere that can present
something else so what I'm doing I'm
trying to make the best out of this
um does it give an answer
sorry
um am I understanding it right
um so so
um the difference between this and a
pseudo-random number generator that
creates a normal distribution like like
our our Norm in in the r language for
example and I'm sure there's something
like that in Python
um uh the difference between those two
is it true that so so
if I had an unrestricted population and
and this table one of marginal um of
means and standard errors and of
frequencies of various things
um I couldn't principle like have a have
a binomial random number pseudo-random
number generator uh for for for those
qualitative traits and a normal um
pseudo random number generator for
things like age and weight although 80s
yeah this is the generation expression
so another describing generation
Expressions that I used to generate each
individual okay but but
um is it is is the is kind of the
take-home message here
that
um because in addition to the clinicians
have said they have a selection criteria
there this is not coming from a normal
distribution this is coming from a
segment of the normal distribution and
that's what you're adding because if
they were saying we we just we randomly
picked a bunch of people from the
population that that uh um panel of
random number generators would do just
as good of a job as this so you're
saying that's the piece that this is
adding is the that restriction criteria
two things first of all it eliminates
Monte Carlo generation level because
whenever you generate something random
you have Randomness this eliminates it
now they've eliminated to the degree of
how much computation power we flow with
it of course but it it does eliminate it
so this is the first thing the second
thing
after you've done this uh it does allow
you to explore how inclusion or
exclusion criterias will affect whatever
you have in the end this is what I meant
you might use it to actually plan how
table one looks like at the end today I
don't know they start a clinical trial
today 10 years from now things might be
totally they select a set of people some
of them will quit the trial some of them
will continue but after 10 years this is
where you collect the data of how table
one would look like at the end correct
can you actually plan the 10 years ahead
this is a tool that might help because
now you can hypothesize and later 10
years later you can see how how good
your hypotheses are but this is a model
and model is Alpha hypothesizing and
they show you how good the information
will fit eventually there was I was just
in mod Sim recently they summoned their
said this famous saying about models I
don't remember the origin they said that
all models are bad some are useful yeah
I don't know the origin but uh
one official you're saying okay maybe so
this is useful to show our understanding
this is a map of our understanding of
what goes on and currently look at this
in the colors do we understand
everything
not necessarily some populations we
cannot explain Sometimes some models
work when you actually run this you can
see some models work much better than
others on some populations but some
models persistent become average ever on
average
quite well
um
hi uh I'm a hardware engineer myself I
design
I simulate transistors I work at Apple
um
so uh part of my design I want to know
the robustness of my response in the
statistical domain so usually when we
designed to three sigma it's easy to run
Monte Carlo like 100 runs usually
dealing with uh if it's uh if it's
normally distributed you just pick up
one Sigma you multiply by three and
you're good but some of our
distributions are not really normal so
and we are interested in looking at high
SEMA values or extreme values or rare
events it depends on you know who you
talk to right
so let's say I design a you guys know
that circuits now they have billions of
transistors right so instead of me
running 1 billion Monte Carlo can I
apply do you see uh so this kind of
missed tool can I apply it to some of
these extreme value Theory or finding
like a point you know in the six to
seven Sigma without me running billions
of Monte Carlo so uh
depends it's
if you're looking about full population
generation of a model to run something
uh
I am not sure that this will be the best
approach but we can talk later to see
whether there's some something that can
be done here uh Mist specifically is
General enough to run multiple types of
Monte Carlo simulation
um it's written in Python and it's free
software so you can test it and play
with it and see whether it's what you
fit what fits you or not and you can
download it through
you know the QR code in the left you'll
be will take you to the missed uh
repository on GitHub
um
but the
if you are looking for
um
some subset of populations a way to
optimize the population to look only at
something specific then maybe the ideas
here that I used inspired from maybe
they'll be helpful for you so you might
want to check it out because basically
what I do is I create a population then
I optimize only to a subset of it but if
you're talking about 12 events you have
to still generate those whoever events
yeah that's the point so the question is
how do you generate the events if they
are so well yeah my goal is to generate
maybe a billion sample which I'm not
going to simulate but I'm just going to
simulate maybe the ones in the Tails or
ah so you can you can you can generate
the entire population then use inspired
to optimize to only the tail that you
are interested in then do on your
simulations from this perspective this
is exactly what Mrs is doing okay so
same idea
hello
um is there any
um so a lot of this is because the raw
data from clinical trials is not made
public and is there any push from
researchers to actually make that data
public from
um from all these clinical trials so
there was a big push towards making a
lot of this information uh public and
you should talk to Alex later because
this is partially what they're doing uh
that is to de-identify some of the data
and put it out also people can use it uh
but uh even though even if you did
Identify some of the data sets think
about it's not everyone in the entire
world will do this because if you're
talking about globally people the laws
in the UK might not be the same in the
US and when they would do some multi
clinical trials that are involved more
than one country this becomes cumbersome
you can see this
but a lot of people
it's it's difficult this is an easy way
to look at data that's already out there
and maybe outdated some of it but maybe
it can be you be useful or not and it's
kind of a generic way because basically
what you do is you take the paper you
read the paper you plug in the data into
table one you plug in the results into
some other place then you plug in a
bunch of models and see how all this
behaves together using high performance
Computing which is today's relatively
cheap
why not try to do this in parallel to
some other methods
okay I think that's all the time we have
thank you very much for an interesting
presentation thank you very much